speaking of really weird decisions being
made by our elected officials I told you
last week
that Senate Republicans passed a bill
preventing Donald Trump from easing
Russian sanctions without their
involvement or approval and at the time
we asked the following question what
will House Republicans do do they do the
same thing as the Senate and say yes
Trump needs to go through us to ease
Russian sanctions or will they be more
sympathetic to Trump which they've been
in general this past the Senate almost
unanimously and it has now failed to
pass the House congressman Kevin Brady
from Texas said that the legislation was
flagged by the house as a blue slip
violation referring to a constitutional
requirement that revenue bills originate
in the house so this is a sort of
technicality where if you are going to
pass a bill that requires House and
Senate approval that is what would be
called a revenue bill it relates to
government spending or revenue it needs
to start in the house and then be
modified if necessary and agreed upon by
the Senate so they're saying this isn't
because House Republicans necessarily
want to do away with Russian sanctions
it's that if you're dealing with
sanctions you're dealing with revenue
and spending and thus it should
originate in the house technically I
guess it's true but a spirit of this
bill is not that it's a revenue bill Pat
well I tend to buy the explanation only
because when you're talking about
Congress there's so much procedure and
precedent that goes on and maybe some
elitist bickering maybe because you know
people in the house or in the lower
house of Congress so they're kind of
envious of the Senators so they want to
be able to hold their ground and keep
their position that's the type of
defense that some people are making
which is listen it's a technicality but
it is a legitimate technicality and
House Republicans back the sanctions
they just need to fix the glitch so to
speak I say let's wait and see now the
explanation is it's a technicality but a
delay is a delay and until it passes it
hasn't passed I just think the fact that
it passed the Senate 97 to 2 means that
it would be really hard to believe that
it wouldn't even
the house even by a simple majority ah
well maybe this is an example of young
Patrick's naivete I want to propose to
you that there's there is an even more
conspiratorial angle here which is
senators deliberately put supportive
Russian sanctions in a so-called revenue
bill knowing that the house would kick
it back on that basis so that they would
almost unanimously be on record as
saying hey I voted for the Russian
sanctions knowing it would never get
past the house because of the
technicality oh so maybe it's a false
flag operation I hesitate to call it a
false flag but I think that we need to
not be overly cynical but we also don't
want to be naive about the reality of
what's going on well we'll see what
happens I hope this does pass the house
as it has passed the Senate because you
have to punish Russia after what they
did meddling in the 2016 campaign well
the funny thing is all of a sudden now
they care about the Constitution right
hey listen constitutionally revenue
bills have to originate in the house the
Constitution was ignored in their
support of Donald Trump's travel bans in
so many other places that I don't even
have to list for you it's all a gong
show folks that's what we're quickly
finding out discuss this with us on
reddit I am on our reddit discussion
forum Pat is sometimes anything every
once in a while when he has time on the
reddit discussion forum and you can be
on it at david pakman.com slash reddit
today's program sponsored in part by tag
adapt the hosting specialists whether
you need dedicated server solutions
virtual private servers cloud server
options custom server solutions
colocation services whatever you need
for your business or project taga dab
and their expert hosting specialists and
support will set you up with what works
for your business or project and their
hosting services support a really wide
range of customers and businesses around
the world including bloggers tech
startups financial traders gamers web
developers and more you can use the code
TDPS 20 to get a twenty british pound
credit towards cloud server
options at signup taga Deb calm /t DPS
with that you can try out their services
and save twenty British pounds about
twenty three twenty four US dollars you
use the code TDPS twenty at signup ta ga
da be com /t dps check it out